we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine
two
david p
here's a caller
not thrilled with my alex jones
impression listen to this
mr pac-man sir if i might offer a
criticism of your show it's that your
alex jones impersonation
needs a lot of work okay see what you
want to do when you're doing an alex
jones impersonation you want to make it
sound like you've just smoked every
cigarette
but you wouldn't know anything about
that you demon rat
no in all seriousness
i do enjoy the show uh thank you for
your interviewing acumen in general and
i was curious if you
uh agree that in part
the rise of trumpism or fascism whatever
it is you want to call it
uh there's some responsibility
of
the people on the left
who
[Music]
perhaps
are performative in their outrage when
something
you know
messed up happens um because it just
kind of seems like there's a whole
wing of supporting trump that deals with
i just want to trigger the libs yeah
listen
there i i'm not doing a both sides thing
but there is some performative outrage
on both sides it's over very different
things and it's tailored and sort of
focused differently
but i've seen performative outrage on
the left as well and i don't participate
in it and
i don't even know that i care to get
into the specifics right now but there's
performative outrage all over now as far
as the alex jones impression is it that
bad globalist
internationalist trotskyite socialist
shun unlike obama trudeau mccrone
and the rest of these zio beasts
i don't know i think it's okay i i
generally don't think my impressions are
very good i also do susan collins
well i was very disappointed to see that
donald trump killed a man but i think
that he's learned his lesson
and i am not in favor of moving forward
with any consequences whatsoever
um what other ones do i do i don't know
my impressions are all like a four out
of ten
i think uh they're they're bad but i
think at least it's passable who i'm
referring to
um
yeah okay anyway let's uh let's move on
on today's bonus show
there is a florida abortion ban
this is fascinating because it's the
opposite of how these things usually
work
there are jewish groups now saying the
florida abortion ban violates the
religious freedom of jewish folks this
is this is absolutely brilliant
there are jewish religious teachings
which say in certain cases you should
have an abortion you should have an
abortion
and
the way that the florida abortion ban is
written would violate the religious
freedom of those jewish folks
to access that abortion and we're going
to talk about that on today's bonus show
secondly
do you remember when um alexander
litvinenko was poisoned by a russian
agent this was a major story um
a few years ago i believe it was
polonium
um
the agent linked to the poisoning of
litvinenko has now died from covid which
is a bizarre turn of events and then
lastly
russia has a rebranded mcdonald's it's
sort of like a mcdonald's clone because
of mcdonald's closing in russia
it's called delicious that's all
we will talk about whether producer pat
can get vegan treats at the new
mcdonald's clone
and we will talk about so many other
things
don't miss today's bonus show i will be
on it pat will join me you can sign up
at
joinpackman.com remember alex jones is
still against you signing up oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad he still thinks it's
predatory that is a freaking predator
right there right i love the bonus show
quite frankly sign up at joinpakman.com
coupon code big voting 22 for a discount
i will see you then or otherwise back
here tomorrow